spider-man and the Green Goblin the
Green Goblin you like that mr. Janus
ended up myself
he's weirdos all gonna have a name now
mr. Jameson spider Bachmann yeah call
the Patent Office copyright the name
Green Goblin I want a quarter every time
somebody says it ha
green meanie spider-man wasn't attacking
the city he was trying to save it that's
slander it is not I resent that slander
is spoken and print it's libel you don't
trust anybody that's your problem
I trust my barber well he was lawyer get
out of here let him sue me get rich like
a normal person
that's what made this country
Jameson slime who's the photographer
takes the pictures of spider-man I don't
know who he is this stuff comes in the
mayor lying it's worth he's the one who
can bring me to I don't know who will
you are useless she set him down tough
guy speak and that gap spider-man I knew
you two were in this together hey kiddo
my mom and dad talk for a minute way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no you're not dead you're an amazing
creature spider-man you and I are not so
different I'm not like you you're a
murderer well to each his own I chose my
path you chose the way of the hero and
they found you amusing for a while the
people of this city but the one thing
they love more than a hero is to see a
hero fail fall die trying
in spite of everything you've done for
them eventually they will hate you
why bother because it's right here's the
real truth there are eight million
people in this city and those teeming
masses exist for the sole purpose of
lifting the few exceptional people onto
their shoulders you may wear exceptional
I could squash you like a bug right now
but I'm offering you a choice
join me imagine what we could accomplish
together what we could create or we
could destroy caused the deaths of
countless innocents it's selfish battle
again and again and again until we're
both dead is that what you want
think about it hero
you